[Music]
wow good afternoon everyone super
excited to see you all here today such
an incredible energy here at the event
I'm Roman I lead developer experience at
oppi and before joining OPP I was also a
founder and like many of you in this
room I actually experienced firsthand
the magic of building with the frontier
models now I'm working on making sure we
offer the most delightful experience for
all of you builders in this room and
what I love the most about this role is
also showing uh the art of the possible
with our AI models and Technologies and
so uh today we're going to go through a
few things uh that uh that the great
capabilities that the open team has
built recently and we'll show some live
demos to really bring them to
life but first I'd i' like to start with
a quick um zoom out on how we've gotten
to where we are
today openi is a research company and
we're working on building AGI in a way
that benefits all of humanity and to
achieve this Mission we believe in
itative deployment we really want to
make the technology enter contact with
reality as early and often as possible
and for that a top Focus for us Aton is
really all of you like the best builders
in the world we really believe strongly
that the best developers and startups
are integral to the G in this like AGI
Mission you guys are the ones that are
going to build the native AI products in
the future so today we have 3 million
developers around the world building on
the open ey platform and we are very
fortunate uh to to have so much
Innovation but I'd like to rewind a
little bit and you know today outside of
this room when people think of openi
they often think of chat GPT first
because that's become like the the
product that has taken the World by
storm a little bit but the first product
was actually not at GPT the first
product we put out there was the
developer platform so back in 2020 at
the time we had gpt3 and that's when we
first started launching it to the public
behind an API uh maybe quick show of
hands actually who in this room have
played uh with the API at the time of
gpt3
already wow that's like more than half
of you you guys are really my crowd here
that's awesome and you know at the time
we kind of got a taste for what AI would
be capable of doing like basic coding
assistance copy editing maybe some very
simple translation but to really put
things in perspective at the time this
was the most or one of the most popular
use cases on the platform AI dungeon
this was like a roleplaying game purely
based on text and it kind of was
generating open-ended stories and you
could navigate uh the world and you know
at at each scenary when you were trying
to look around it would generate new
text so that was kind of the
state-ofthe-art at the time obviously in
2023 gp4 changed the game it completely
um changed the way we thought about AI
it got better at reasoning it get more
creative more specific it could start
being better at coding and reasoning
about complex problems and it could use
tools also interpret data and kind of
that dramatically expanded the aperture
of the possibilities with the
platform we've had a great Fortune of
working with many many developers and
companies like integrating gp4 in their
own apps and servic
and this is just one example among many
uh Spotify when they took um the our
models to kind of generate playist on
the Fly based on your music taste and
history but the one thing I want to
highlight today in this talk is that GPT
was also the beginning of our
multimodality journey this is the very
first time where we introduced like
Vision capabilities and suddenly gp4
could analyze and interpret data um such
as images photos Etc not just p text and
then with gp4 tubo for the first time we
brought Vision capabilities into the
same model right inside so that you can
have the exact same model that does the
the two modalities at the same
time and of course last month we kind of
took a step further with multimodality
and that brings us to GPT foro so GPT
for is our new flagship model that that
can reason across audio video and text
all in real time and thank thanks to its
native image and audio capabilities we
really think that you can now build uh
very natural human computer interactions
in a way that we've never seen
before and so the reason we call it GPT
4 is because O is for Omni Omni model if
you will and that that's because we
brought all of these modalities into one
single model for you to interact with
and there are like many things that are
very unique and interesting about GPT
for but I'd like to call out a couple
step function changes here the first one
is that it's really a big step towards
like this like you know multimodality
future with like Ultra fast latency for
the first time like I'm not sure if many
of you have played with chat GPT with
voice mode before or if you've tried to
build your own voice assistance but you
kind of had to stitch kind of three
models together first like whisper for
translation then gp4 for reasoning and
then ultimately Text to Speech but of
course that kind of added a loss of
context and some latency along the way
now we have all of that into a single
model and for all of you developers
what's really exciting too is that for
the same kind of state-of-the-art
reasoning capabilities that we offer
with gp4 we also Shi massive efficiency
improvements and that means that in turn
we've been able to turn those efficiency
uh gains back to you so as a result um
gp4 is twice as fast as gp4 turbo it's
also half the price and we also increase
drastically the rate limits I I actually
have like five higher rate limits on
this slide but we kind of like always
pushing them higher and we really want
to live in a world where there's not
even any rate limits so you can build
with no
limits but with all that said I'd like
to give you a glimpse into GPT 4 uh and
so we're going to switch over to my Mac
here so for this first live demo I'm
going to bring up a chat GPT for desktop
and all I have to do is Click option uh
space and I'm going to bring the voice
mode right here
hey CH GPT how are you hey I'm doing
great thanks for asking how about you
I'm great I'm actually on stage at the
AI engineer Worlds Fair in San Francisco
uh could you greet the audience we have
some amazing developers here in the room
hey everyone it's awesome to be
virtually here at the AI engineer
World's Fair in San Francisco so CH I
kind of like how you started but I
really want you to bring the energy like
people are very excited here so make
this more alive and also don't for
people are also tuning in from the live
stream so don't forget about them hello
San Francisco and to everyone joining us
on the live stream welcome to the AI
engineer Worlds Fair we've got an
incredible lineup and a ton of energy
here today let's dive into all the
exciting Tech and Innovation that's much
better thank you Chad GPT I think they
re enjoyed
that here if you need anything else just
let me know hope the event goes
fantastically yeah maybe one thing you
could do like since we have a crowd of
the best Builders out there can you
whisper one secret that's really
precious but has their building the
future of their AI native products what
should they know all right just between
us remember the key to building great AI
native products is focusing on
responsible and
ethical Pary and glad you liked it can
you whisper another one but even lower
like very very very
slow sure here's one more it's crucial
to keep your AI adaptable and
scalable technology evolves fast your
products should
Doo cool so what thank
you a couple things to call out here but
first of all like you can see the
latency is pretty impressive like it's
very much like natural in a conversation
and and there's Lally no difference with
talking to humans it's almost too fast
at times I would say um the second thing
that's really cool is that it
understands emotion and can generate
tones you know it could whisper it could
bring the energy it could be more alive
but also I can jump back in the
conversation at any time I can interrupt
the model and I doesn't I don't have to
wait for the audio output to finish and
that's really cool to have something
much more natural uh versus what we what
we knew before so the next thing I'd
like to to show you of course we're
talking of modalities so let's bring the
second modality I'd like to turn on
camera
here anytime hey chpt can you now see
me yes I can see you yeah you know you
don't have to whisper anymore you can
talk normally
now got it how's the event going it's
good um do I look good actually because
I'm in front of a lot of people
here you look great ready for the
spotlight awesome okay so give me a
second I'm going toy I'm going to try to
draw something for you and and I'll I'll
show it to you sounds good I'm curious
to see what you come up
with just give me a few more seconds you
know take your time I'm here whenever
you're
ready pretty
patient no rush I'm always here when
you're ready to Okay so based on what I
drew here can you take a guess on where
I am and also can you translate what I
wrote yes that's the Golden Gate Bridge
so you must be in San Francisco and you
wrote bonjour developer which means
hello developers in French pretty cool
all right
um this was a pretty poor Bridge uh but
Chad GPT is pretty clever um next I have
this book can you take a look Chad GPT
what is this
yeah that's poor Charlie's Almanac by
Charlie Munger it's a collection of the
speeches talks and life philosophy
Munger is known for his wisdom on
investing and decision can you uh can
you just give me a random number between
one and
400 sure how about
126 126 here we go okay page 126 can you
give me like a brief overview of what's
happening on this
page it looks like this page talks about
Coco Chanel rule for Success it mentions
that Chanel focused on identifying the
qualities her customers wanted and made
sure to offer them essentially
understanding your audience desires is
key to success would you like a bit more
detail from the page no I think I'm good
this is pretty amazing you you read
faster than I could read just one line
so it's pretty amazing all right um cool
next I'd like to show you something else
so instead of camera I'll go real quick
here and uh instead of sharing camera
I'll share my screen so I'm going to
bring up chat GPT one more time here
with audio
capabilities I'm going to reduce this
window a little
bit can you clar okay CH GPT I'm going
to share my screen with you can you see
what I
see yes I can see your screen what are
we looking at here uh well I'm I'm
currently working on this app uh you
know it's a travel apps and I'd like to
make it a little better um but there's
one thing that I'm not quite sure about
doing and I'd like your help so if I go
to this tab here and if I try to put the
final touches on it feels like the
responsiveness is not really good like
what do you
think I see what you mean when you
switch to the mobile view the layout
looks a bit cramped and the images seem
squished have you considered using media
queries to adjust the layout for smaller
screens so it might let's take a look at
the code here uh maybe you could help me
I'm going to send you first like this
whole component um I'm going to copy the
code over to you if you can take a look
uh can you give me like a on line
overview of what's going on in that
one this code defines a react hook use
assistant that manages interactions with
an AI assistant it handles sending and
receiving messages file uploads and
streaming responses from a server okay
cool I don't think that's where we need
to change some stuff I think it might be
over here in the Discover component what
do you
think yeah it does look like this is
where the layout is being set for those
end descriptions so I'm using Tailwind
CSS um what should I do exactly to going
to change it and make it responsive
here you could adjust the grid color
attributes on mobile sizes by using
mobile what's the what's the kind of
prefix I should use for mobile screens
then you can use the SM prefix for small
screens okay right that
I say yeah this and maybe for uh other
should that is that looking right like
medium screen maybe two and then we keep
the three for Larch screens something
like
that yeah that looks good adjusting the
call Howes take a look now what do you
think it looks much better the images
and
layout great job solving that any else
you want to tweak
[Applause]
so I really like using chat GPT on
desktop as a coding assistant but of
course this was a very trivial use case
but what's also even more interesting is
when you start reasoning out loud with
Chad GPT to build something but you also
tell like hey actually I'm going to get
cursor to do it but what should I prom
cursor and I've done that many times
it's also pretty amazing to see how both
of them can interact across modalities
but let's go back to my presentation
please I'd like to give you a little bit
of a sneak peek of what's on our mind
what are we working on next at a AI as
we think about these modalities in the
future of models so there are four
things that we're currently top of that
are currently top of mind for us
especially for all of you developers
building on the platform the first thing
is textual intelligence of course as you
can tell we're extremely excited about
modalities but we also think that
increasing textual intelligence is still
very key uh to unlock the
transformational value of AI and we
expect the potential uh of llms
intelligence that we expect that
potential to be like still very huge in
the future those models today they're
pretty good you know as we can tell we
we're building things with them but at
the same time what's really cool to
realize that is that they the dumbers
they'll ever be will always have better
models coming up and if you will like
it's almost like we have first graders
working alongside us they still make
mistakes every now and then but we
expect that in a year from now they
might be like completely different and
unrecognizable from what we have today
they could become Master students In The
Bleak of an eye in multiple disciplines
like Medical research or scientific
reasoning to reex the next Frontier
Model will have such a a function change
in reasoning improvements
again the second are Focus that we're
excited about is like faster and cheaper
models and we know that not every use
case requires like the highest
intelligence of course GPT Force pricing
has decreased significantly uh 80% in
fact over a year but we also want to in
introduce like more models over time so
we want these models to be cheaper for
you all to build we want to have models
of different sizes we don't really have
timelines to share today but that's
something we very excited about as well
and finally we want to help you run uh
async workloads we launched a couple
months ago the batch API and we're
seeing like tremendous success already
especially For Those modalities say you
have like documents to analyze with
vision with or photos or images all that
can be batched for another 50% uh
discount on pricing third we also
believe in model customization we really
believe that every company every
organization will have a customized
model and we have like a wide range of
offering here I'm sure many of you here
have tried our fine tuning API it's
completely available for for anyone to
build with but we also assist companies
all the way like Harvey for instance uh
a startup that's building a product uh
for law firms and they were able to kind
of customize GPT 4 entirely on us case
law and they've seen like amazing
results in doing so and last we'll
continue to invest in enabling AG agents
we're extremely excited about the future
of agents and we share a little bit
about that Vision back in November at
death day and agents will be able to
perceive interact with the world using
all of these modalities just like human
beings and once again that's where the
multimodality story comes into play
Imagine an agent being able to kind of
coordinate with multiple AI systems but
also securely access your data and and
even yes manage your calendar and things
like that we're very excited about
agents dein of course is an amazing
example of what agents can become like
cognition Labs has built this awesome uh
this awesome like software engineer that
can a code alongside you but he's able
to break down complex task and actually
um you know brse the documentation
online submit pool request and so on and
so forth it's really a glimpse into uh
what we can expect for the future of
agents and with all that of that it's no
surprise that in fact po gram realized
um a few months ago that like often 20
or 22y old sorry programmers are often
as good if not better than 28y old
programmers and that's because they have
these amazing AI tools at their
fingertips so with that I'd like to
switch to another demo to kind of show
you this time not chat GPT but rather
like what we can build with these
modalities so in the title of this talk
I did not mention video but I'm sure
most of you have seen Sora the preview
of our kind of diffusion model that's
able to generate video from a very
simple uh prompt and this is one of them
so uh in the interest of time I've
already sent this prompt to Sora
describing a documentary with a tree
frog very precise on what I'm expecting
and if I click here this is what came
out of
[Music]
Sora it's pretty
cool but next what I'd like to do is
going of bring this video to life you
know and and here what I'm doing is like
I simply sliced frames out of the video
of Sora and what I'm going to do next is
very simple I'm going to send these six
frames over to um to GPT f with vision
with this prompt if you're curious and
I'm going to tell it to narrate what it
sees as if it was a narrator so going
back here I'm going to click analyze and
narrate again this is all happening in
real time so every single time the story
is unique and I'm just discovering it
like all of you and boom that's it so
that's what gp4 with vision was able to
create based on what it saw in those
frames so it's pretty
magical but last but not least I wanted
to show you one thing that we also
previewed recently uh and it's our voice
engine model the voice engine model is
the ability for us to create custom
voices based on very short clips and of
course we take safety very responsibly
so this is not a model that's broadly
available just yet uh but I wanted to
give you sneak peek today of how it
works and also the voice engine is what
we use internally with actors to bring
the voices you know in the API or in ch
GPT so here I'm going to go ahead and
show you a quick demo hey so I'm on
stage at the uh AI engineer World Fair I
just uh need to record a few seconds of
my voice I'm super excited to see the
audience that's really captivated by
these modalities and what we can now
build uh on the open ey platform all
right hey so I'm on stage at the uh
engineer World Fair I just yeah sounds
like it's perfect uh that's all we need
so now to bring it all bring us all
together here what I'm going to do is
I'm going to take this clip I'm going to
take the script that we just generated
and I'm sending all of it back to um the
voice engine and we'll see what
[Music]
happens in the heart of the dense Misty
Forest a vibrant frog makes its careful
way along a Cross covered Branch its
bright green body adorned with black and
yellow patterns stands out amidst the
Lush foliage I can also have it
translate in multiple languages so let's
try
French and for those who know me that's
actually a sound I speak
French maybe one last one with Japanese
all right um thank you let's go back
real quick to the to the
slides and of course this is one very
specific examples of bringing modalities
together with you know Sora videos GPT 4
and vision the voice engine that we have
not released yet but I hope this
inspires you to see how you can kind of
picture the future with these modalities
combined together so to wrap up we're
focused on these four things textual
intelligence to drive it up uh making
our models faster and and more
affordable so you all can scale we're
thinking about customizable uh models
for your needs and finally making sure
you can build for this multimodal future
and agents and if there's one thing I
want to leave you off with today is that
our goal is not for you guys to spend
more with openi but our goal is for you
to build more with openi because let's
remember we're still in the very early
Innings of that transition and it's a
fundamental shift in how we think and
build software every day so we really
want to help you in that transition
we're dedicated to supporting developers
startups we love feedback so if there's
anything we could do better please come
find me after this talk and you know
this is really like the most exciting
time to be building an AI native company
so we want you to bet on the future of
AI and and we know that bold Builders
like all of you are going to come up
with the future and and invent it before
anyone else so with that thank you so
much and we can't wait to see what
you're going to build with those new
modalities and reinvent software 2.0
[Music]